ترقص مع ماسك لاكثر من قصه شهره ونفودا في
العالم يثير القلق حول كيفيه اداره
العملاق الازرق الملك الجديد تعاهد وبدا
بتنفيذ وعوده قالها تويتر ليس مجانيه
راينا ذلك اقلها على اصحاب علامات التوثيق
الزرقاء لكن ما قد يثير القلق اكثر حين
اشار الى ان الكلام غير المقيد يجب ان
يكون هو القاعده على الموقع
فالمقابل يواجهه ماسك الذي يزعم بانه مطلق
حريه التعبير الظهوطا كبيره وخصوصا فيما
يتعلق بالمعلومات المضلله وخطاب الكراهيه
والتطرف على المنصه وهو ما بدلا فتنه وعيد
استحوا به على المنصه نسبه الافتراء
العنصريه ارتفعت بالفن و700 700 في المئه
الف و700% وبلغ الثروهتها عند 200 25 شهر
كل خمس ثواني وذلك وفقا لبياناتنا من ذا
تاماينر شريكه تويتر الرسميه اوروبا كلها
التي تئن تحت وطاه الاحتجاجات بسبب اسعار
الطاقه قلقه من تخفيف الاشراف على المحتوى
والمفوض الاوروبي المكلف بالاشراف على
السوق الرقميه شدد على ان العصفور سيحلق
نعم لكن وابقى القوانين الاوروبيه غير انا
مثير للقلق هو ما يمكن ان يخلقه ماسك من
فوضى اكبر صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وصفت الرجل
بانه اللاعب اساسي في الفوضى الجيوس
السياسيه كيف
تغريداته بشان مناطق الصراع في العالم مثل
حرب اوكرانيا تظاهرات ايران وازمه الصين و
تايوان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]